hello time anywhere and today I'm going
to tell you three things about three -
not quite good classroom and you I'm
going to tell you what is we're tube
what do I do I do it and why should you
consider doing something like it so
number one what is your - well it's a
unfortunately named YouTube channel one
of my ex students made it up or the name
and it's stuck and I have not boughten
been one since where I upload just my
classroom lessons I set up a camera and
it's lights any microphone and keep
playing and then my regular life lesson
unfolds now what is the flipped
classroom can I get a show of hands how
many of you have heard of Khan Academy
yeah okay excellent thank you guys that
now the flipped classroom for those of
you who either be living under a rock or
raise your hand out of peer pressure I'm
hope they are do it - the idea of the
flipped classroom is taking what happens
normally in a cost which is instruction
and explanation and flipping around for
what usually happens at home which is
exercises and aptly named homework right
so it's turning it the other way around
Khan Academy does it with this kind of
video there's writing on the video and
there's a soothing voice in the
background explaining what's going on
now I call we shoot the not quite fits
classroom because I do not do this I do
this it's just my regular lesson now I
do that for two reasons number one I
don't have time to pre-record videos
beforehand during summer I have three
young children and they keep me very
busy so instead I just do it during my
lesson but secondly the reason why I
don't do the pre-recording thing is
because I think one of the best thing
that you all have to experience in maths
teaching is about learning moment the
learning women when you're there and you
are exploring are we crazy
counterintuitive idea complete with you
know questioning and perplexity and
apparently lots of arm waving right
I think you're crazy to rob yourself of
that okay so that's why I had to it that
way but why do I do it let me give you
four reasons number one short form video
of the kind that YouTube is made famous
is the medium of our students generation
and it's not just them we as teachers we
know this you don't stand up there and
talk and talk and talk you've got to do
bits an explanation bit of an example
let them have a gun don't keep them rat
from actually doing the mats into it
enjoy pieces of course there are times
for extended discourses but you know go
on in the days really of the forty
minute doctor on the VHS instead long
live the eight to ten minute video from
crash course veritasium vsauce those
kinds of guys that was reason number one
reason number two I just want to create
some free Australian resources out there
whether we like it or not our students
are going to the internet for help and
they're finding you know on Google you
look for what but on YouTube you find
how but most of the how is us right and
so kids get up there and they're like
what socks I do I do pre calculus I
don't know and I'm a little bit so we
need a lot of free just really start
there for students to access a number
three to enable me to be more flexible
with that precious time that I have in
class okay here's the idea just like in
the kitchen the mathematics classroom is
figurative exploration and inquiry and
perplexing right but it's also filled
with algorithms step-by-step processes
that must be mastered by practice and
there's no one way now please tell me
I'm not the only math teacher who
respect listen up a lesson explaining
something and then moving around all
these individual tables to help students
do how do I do the quadratic formula how
do its completing squared I don't get it
right so you sit down in them you help
them but you can only do that for so
long and unfortunately we don't usually
have two chefs in the classroom right so
that enables me to use the clock the
time I haven't
more freely okay last that reason why I
do it the school I used to teach at was
literally famous for its academic
excellence but the thing that astonished
me most about it was that all the
students were so involved in
extracurricular activities
cadets musical si si prefect social
justice you name it they're all great
things but they take off now I really
resented the idea that our students were
being inadvertently punished
academically for pursuing these great
kinds of initiatives because they we
lose lessons right so the videos are
kind of a way for them to catch up the
lessons that they miss them as was
mentioned before the the sequential
nature nature of Matt's means that's
really essential okay now just one
little of ps/2 why I do it in this
reason is anyone hands up same I
recognize what that building is okay you
are all very fortunate because this
building well this this is the front
door of the Children Hospital and West
me now you are all fortunate to not
recognize it but Howard she'll join our
students are not all so fortunate a
couple years ago I had a very very
moving experience had the privilege of
teaching a student who was very very
young in that hospital over time and if
you know anyone who's been very ill one
of the things you crave the most it's
just to feel normal
just to do normal things not to have
life be appointment after appointment
after treatment after recovery the boy I
taught was able to keep up with the
class and when he was in class for a few
weeks at a time it wasn't like he was
just sort of deadweight dragging the
class down because he'd been keeping up
with us so that was one of the really
important reasons why I did this that
was four reasons why I do it why should
you do it well if your lecturers are
still talking about the importance of
reflection as much as they did when I
was at University then you all know how
important it is to actively an
objectively critique your own pedagogy
right well I can tell you nothing is as
objective as a camera
right now mature to give yourself a
sense of progress as a teacher right
those first few years were you just
struggling to work out how to do
anything they can be brutal right some
people are you know Naturals they just
walk into the classroom and they're
awesome but the rest of us to mere
mortals we need a reminder of the fact
that where we're growing as teachers
right and that might not be obvious day
to day it's certainly not obvious period
one the six but over period of years
you can see a self change and that's
really amazing thirdly to be part of the
global movements that's sharing
education for free with the whole world
now I went to teaching because we live
in a country where you can get
world-class education for free and
things like YouTube EDU are trying to do
that on mass through the internet places
like socratic org call it crowd teaching
which like crowdsourcing is making all
kinds of new things possible through the
internet one last reason why should you
do it
why should consider doing something is
crazy just sticking a camera in your
classroom well it's to challenge
yourself to provide the most innovative
and unclear expectations
explanations that you can right it's
scary for having it there but it'll push
you to true to do the best lessons that
are possible Thanks